thank you
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys and we are
very careful boys and today we're
talking about how we all doing a little
chicken hey check-in time
checking time and we're going to start
unfortunately with Nick Dunn
get it out of the way huh next nine
minutes we have to break his wall down
for a while it's good these days what
are you doing you mean like just what
I'm doing right now are like doing it
I'm just sitting I'm just sitting with
the with the boys and Colleen you know
we're three quarters of the way through
of 2023 has the year been good for you
wow have you been have you been you
didn't end the year with the bang did
you do everything you wanted to do this
year
yeah I think it's going along a lot
better than I thought it was going to be
honestly yeah
um I feel like uh work wise it's been
really good
we're we're Trucking along on the goals
that I kind of set for myself so that's
pretty cool what are some of the goals
just monetarily oh just just hitting
things that you want to hit and building
the online side and the in-person stuff
so that's cool it's fun the gym is
making money awesome the students are
great like it's it's overall work wise
is great
um
the puppies you know my kids they're a
little pain in the ass a little bit
that's been a little tougher than I
thought it was gonna be but it's okay
um and then yeah dude everything's good
everything I can't really
read some books I just feel like uh yeah
for sure I feel like it's good I feel
like it's truck I have nothing to
complain about right now so this year is
way better than last year so far but
yeah for sure less stressful but also
yeah less stressful what was stressful
before last year just work [__] you know
just trying to bounce back trying to
figure out like what the [__] is gonna
happen you know after Kobe I'll teach
you how to tell a good story you set it
up with how [__] shitty your life was
last year and what all the [__]
things pissed you off and how you
overcame it this year because that is
the truth I didn't admit I need to build
it but last year like even it was a
little scary it wasn't even that bad
like I I
I just feel like I'm real lucky dude I
don't know I just feel like it's things
are Trucking along bro yeah sometimes
jealous why is he got everything this
guy I don't know he's got the looks
Joe looks like he was he's like the
villain in your life and he's he's he
hasn't succeeded at defeating
he's super mad man
he's already chipping away I'm gonna ask
you numerically what were your goals
were and then where where how did you
surpass it by how much he's like I was
only making 10 grand yeah yeah that's
all I want to make a hundred
numerically what were the goals that you
said and then what did you end up what
did you end up with do you
should I say that yeah is it okay to say
yeah
no I don't want to talk about it
wow we came really close [__] close to
the truthful I see why Joe wants to
destroy it yeah you should want to
destroy me do you guys talk about that
[__] openly yeah like how much money
Joe has a video dedicated how much you
lost no [__] them clearly how much money
slipped through my fingers and yeah that
ain't even the [__] different right
how much money you're making a month
you're not bragging yeah
if you don't feel comfortable you don't
feel comfortable yeah honestly I don't
want to talk about 28 000 into a [__]
million dollars twice let's go baby suck
my dick and if you want to talk [__] you
have to admit that I turned twenty eight
thousand dollars in a million dollars
first before I lost it
yeah baby let's go how are you feeling
emotionally this year
I don't want to talk about that
um emotionally
you know I've been thinking about a lot
recently I feel like a piece of [__] son
I feel all real yeah I feel like that me
too which one to your dad or to your mom
uh prior to my mom just because I feel
like I can spend more time with her but
sometimes like she annoying no it's not
that she's annoying it's just like
I always feel like there's just so much
stuff to do you know what I mean where I
just feel like [__] like oh I I kind of
I procrastinate on that like I don't I
feel like I don't make enough that's
when you think of things to do when you
can visit your mom right that you go oh
actually I could go do this well you
know what I what I've noticed I think
there's most people have two lists in
their brain yeah one's a logical
physical list right like what I need to
do my career whatever but there's and
but there's actually one free list
that's like social psychological
relationship based but because that
doesn't have like a certain guaranteed
Roi you think it's not that important
yeah but then there are times where you
go dude if I just call my mom like once
a week that would make her the happiest
woman like it's like it's and it's free
right and it's like it can and it can
add so much more value to your life but
I think we're so focused on the physical
logical list that we try to like bang
out all the time I think that's true
like so no I try to get my mom to come
in the gym at least once a week where I
train her yeah wow because I'm trying to
get her to like you know get more fit
that's awesome she was like Austria
osteoporosis so she gotta lift weights
exactly right so I try to do that stuff
for her at least once a week does that
mean that the bones are weak yeah you're
getting like literally brutal bones yes
but usually in her hip it's dangerous
yeah so it's like you gotta put put her
on that bear like [__] you know what I'm
saying
um but yeah so that's been good but I
feel like I need to do this to spend
more time outside of like the hour that
I have with her but you do that though I
try so yeah I try to do these once a
week and then even my sister too I don't
spend enough time with my sister I don't
think and I feel like a [__] back
brother for that you are but thank you
for opening up yeah of course
a piece of [__] absent family member I
do feel like a piece of [__] total
shipping
um I have a lot going on actually right
now that's not that's awesome I mean in
different aspects oh it was a bad one
there's there's mixtures
um work is decently busy right now which
is good
yeah that really helps you know the car
financing situation yeah
[__]
um yes I was a mix of car getting stolen
um Joe lending me his car for a month
and a half which nobody else probably
doesn't we all know
I have many trucks that's awesome just
so unnecessary but so generous so
helpful it kind of creepily helpful not
ulterior motives
now that I think about it
well some some would call that a toxic
box
a classic
Boxing class actually yeah work
um I I am a quite toxic boss huh I heard
that I've heard the [__] quite the
opposite
um so work works good
um I feel like my friendships have
developed more that's good which is good
because my brother just recently moved
out of L.A music yeah where do you move
to he moved to uh live with my mom and
help her oh yeah we're so you know it's
a it's a big sacrifice in a way to
um you know for his own life that is
also extremely needed and you know I'm
glad that they have each other and my
mom needs help and
um just the industry is not working
right now too like he's an actor he does
his Dons he does all that so it's just
it didn't make sense for him to stay
especially with my mom needing help yeah
he wouldn't be allowed to work anyway
wonderful too because like I can't
focus on what I need to be doing if I
don't feel like she's being taken care
of yeah
so that's a big one you know like my
rock is not here anymore
um
do you feel lonely or
um in some ways yeah how many brothers
do you have this one oh well technically
two but just one okay just one
um and then
um just really been like
focusing on Fitness that's been like my
main thing that's very psychologically
healthy yeah sure yeah that helps a lot
um and I just want to get to like the
peak stage of
my physical ability Marco Robbie I mean
uh Gal Gadot yeah you want to be mid
yeah
um well I've always like dabbled in it
right I've always like my brother was a
bodybuilder
um and you know I kind of dabbled in it
with him I did boxing
um you know I worked out with him a ton
I trained with Hamilton
um and I always kind of like was on the
cusp of like maybe maybe I want to go
into this maybe I don't
um and then I'm just like you know what
I just turned 31. so I was like I just
never thank you
July 30th oh [__] happy birthday happy
birthday
my brothers was his first so happy
birthday to him too all right worthy
Lance
[__] your parents had you guys a month
apart yeah my mom a year and a day apart
yeah
that was a really damn that was fast all
three trimesters in just
dude Lionheart and your Leo that you're
a nightmare I bet yeah you're a
nightmare yeah it's very intimidating
um what was I talking about Fitness yeah
um yeah I just want to like challenge
myself mentally and physically to a
stage that I feel like I always was on
the cusp of doing it
um and then I just recently kind of got
into a little bit of an injury so oh
there's that too so but we don't think
she's that
it's a little overuses we're gonna be
okay it's not part of it that's nothing
yeah and then also
debating if I want to stay in LA
still that's still been the conversation
for her where would it go I maybe know a
little bit about this
I don't know if I would be happy in Las
Vegas guys I feel like Las Vegas is like
for people who have like partners and
families and like you know it's it's
like not there yet I'm not there yet oh
that's right I feel like to be that
single lady I need to find like another
I don't even know if it's a city but it
needs to be somewhere where I can double
double my workload as far as like film
yeah Georgia but then I also like here's
the thing like things happen so
frequently and randomly when it comes to
like jobs that you know if I need to
make a quick like five six thousand
dollars off of a random job that is
booked in LA and I'm in Nashville or
something it's very hard to do that so
I'm kind of stuck here so it is easier
to be in Nevada
well that's
[Music]
so
they charge you 70 bucks for a [__]
bag yeah oh now your tickets 200 bucks
so yeah I don't know a lot of things to
figure out well done keep going yeah
What's your deal dude
uh I woke up the other day thinking you
know what this is probably the happiest
I've been and that's awesome yeah
because the yes thank you guys yeah
because I don't know if you remember but
I I was telling you this like a couple
years ago where I was like you know
what's crazy is we would just say and
speak this into the air like wouldn't it
be great if our life was like this and
then every single time we've executed
every single idea that we've had about
like what if YouTube was a full-time job
or what if this was that right and then
so
I feel like at that point
my mind started to believe that anything
that I just wished would work and so
something happened along the way where
everything was just normal like
everything just you you lose kind of
gratitude and you're just in the mix it
normalizes yeah and then like we
um I think I was going through this
weird
I don't know if depression is the right
word but it was a losing a sense of self
where I saw that with you yeah I knew
all my goals I knew what I wanted
at one point and then I got to a point
where you know I wasn't in the best
relationship and and and it was it was a
very tough time even with my career my
choices I was like oh this is not
actually I'm not like doing things and
living how I want to live
and then so you're living a drained life
I was tired I was like yeah there was
all kinds of issues and then rebuilding
and sorting it out like how did it get
here and like what happened along the
way where I lost focus and what do I
care about now like what you know so
there was a lot of that and then covet
during covet I was like yeah uh maybe I
just want to retire maybe I'm burnt out
maybe I did too much right and then so
that's when the whole year we just
played like me and my buddies just
snowboarded as much as we wanted to we
did all kinds of [__]
and then I realized like living a life
of just pleasure is pretty boring after
month too where like you can swim all
you want and play all you want but then
like there's something else that you
need to produce or create or give or
earn or something right and also I
wanted like maybe you know to build a
group or whatever it was in my head is
like oh I had a great time with my JK
crew maybe that's what I needed and then
later
I think just looking back I didn't know
that my head was like was saying like
you're ready for a stage in life to go
to the next part which is family
building
being an adult doing this it's not about
like making a mark creating content but
it's really about like how do you build
a community and and those are the things
I think that I was searching for which I
I woke up one day and going like oh [__]
this is what I was planning
subconsciously and I executed because me
and David were talking about this like
three years ago like hey wouldn't it be
cool if we had a business and why we
just lived here and I'm like yeah that
would be awesome let's do it and then
infested it almost yeah and then I I
mean like
it's it's something where like I'm
working toward it and in the process I'm
like yo this is [__] annoying this is
hard this is crazy I'm I might lose a
lot of money people have no idea what
you went through yeah yeah
I mean I I even got to the point where
like I was losing 5K a month I only had
like
10 20 grand in my account I was pulling
loans I was you know I was at a really
like it's like my net worth on paper
might look like hey you got this and I
can get loans but like in my actual
account and how much was coming in every
month was like oh [__] we gotta get we
got to get this going I don't know what
the [__] is gonna happen in three months
and I calculated I got four [__]
months until I'm wiped out and I gotta
start selling my rings my guns my my
everything and then I'm like yeah it was
a [__] weird time and then so
now I'm act like this month I'm breaking
even
so then so then I think like waking up
to that and then even in Hawaii I wasn't
living the dream I was like building a
business right and it's like a
self-inflicted torture that I did but
then I in that process I lost the whole
overall goal which was
I imagined myself waking up swimming
coming into work I have these lovely
employees that I I'm just like you guys
are [__] awesome we're growing
together I'm learning with them that was
the imagination it wasn't playing out
like that and just the other week it
played exactly like that nice I've met
up with my buddy brownie five in the
morning we were [__] surfing nice and
I'm like let's go after that I I get on
a [__] Zoom business meeting in the
parking lot at the beach last time and
I'm talking to these business suits like
yo I'm at the beach and then after that
and the suit's here
this is my dream
great dude wow great what are you saying
[__] this guy wearing a wetsuit cover
the microphone the windscreen for the
[__] thing and I'm there like you
know I come home and like you know it's
it's [__] it's it's I had like
Hannah's there she's like cooked me
something and then like I'm just like
how this is [__] dope I uh this is
what I wanted and two years later it
panned out and then it was like and then
I was thinking you know I probably
wouldn't appreciated this without the
torture
that's true that's very real because I
was thinking about I was talking about
this Dad I was like she's like I think
it was meant for you to lose that money
and I'm like why
and then she goes well
you probably would have solved this
problem of like like with jumbee and all
that you wouldn't just throw money at
the situation you hired a manager done
it and it just would have been like
watching passive and then she's like you
wouldn't have learned all the business
skills that you did through this yeah
and appreciate it that's true and we
also bonded as a family there like like
so many things happened from that you
know like just a wise lady yeah our
relationship got stronger my nephews
became men you know that's cool like
because they moved in with me yeah they
you know they never worked
ever they're not lazy but the experience
that we got to share together I saw them
from timid quiet boys to now like
confident guys giving instructions to
people and guiding and mentoring and I
was like that is [__] sick yeah but
yeah I feel great
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker have you ever looked online and
went shopping and said man look at all
these cool sunglasses but you know what
I don't know if any of these are gonna
look good on my face so I'll just bother
to not buying them have you ever felt
that because I know exactly how that
feels like and so that's why I like
working here with Warby Parker because
because you could do their home try on
kit you can pick the different types of
glasses that you feel fits your face and
then they'll send it to you you put it
on your face and you look at yourself in
a mirror and go sexy and smooth and you
either get to keep it or if you don't
like it you send it right back Warby
Parker offers you everything for happier
eyes you got eyeglasses sunglasses
contacts and even eye exams and you can
shop with them online or in stores
glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses that's a good deal
try Warby Parker's free home try on
program order five pairs of glasses to
try on at home for free like Joe was
talking about there's no obligation to
buy
ships free and even includes a free
prepaid shipping label try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record
um I think for me I don't know if I have
one thing that I that I know is
different and is a very good thing is
that like this is probably the most like
secure that I've ever felt in my own
like internally like about myself
because like I spent so many years just
being closet insecure about a lot of
[__]
and um or I felt like kind of like I was
I always thought I was emotionally
fragile because I things would just
affect me like in an unhealthy degree
and I think now
which is like something is it like when
you go home it affects you because it
feels like nothing affects you like when
we're like around yeah is it like at
home you go home and you're like oh yeah
that kind of hit me things come in I
think just like I mean not since I've
been here but like growing up in like my
teen years and in my early 20s my even
my early 30s like I was very like
um
I would just think too much like I would
just internalize a lot of [__] and if I
felt offended they people would be like
ah nothing [__] offends this guy but
then I would be wrestling with it like
mentally yeah and I would eventually get
to the right place but I would have to
take a [__] trip yeah
um and I think like that hurt a lot of
my like romantic relationships because I
just [__] make more problems in my
head
um but slowly like over time like I kind
of even in the beginning of my
relationship with smack I was still kind
of like that and it would be
a harder time to arrive at the
productive conclusion like if something
she said I felt like what the [__] was
the meaning behind that you know just
unnecessary [__] but I think like
now it's the most I've
stopped and realized like oh I don't
even if I didn't have this problem in
the past couple years I think now I've
realized it's been gone and it didn't
hit me until this year wow that's cool
it didn't hit me that I was
authentically fine instead of having a
trying to be fine like instead of like
going through the motion and like even
though it's it's a good result to go
okay no it doesn't bug me but like now
it happens automatically that I'm like
okay with [__] is there like a specific
moment that you just had that realizing
I think it's just like late ass maturity
or something I don't know what it is I
think I just are you just so used to
these habits that you have you're like
an old naked man at the gym who doesn't
go [__]
you got bad
that's cool man and you know what it
also is it's like getting older it's
pretty [__] hard like especially
um one of my things was like I was
afraid of uh
you know that like whole Asian thing
where you look so young for so many
years and then you turn into a turtle
exactly you turn into a turtle and I'm
like is this the turtle year like is
this something's gonna happen
you know oh my God and then um and then
I I just started to just not give a [__]
anymore I'm just like I think it's fine
if the turtle comes the turtle yeah and
I like I like how things have turned out
I'm glad I didn't you know Botox myself
to a [__] another person yeah right
I'm fine with it yeah you look great
thanks man but I think
um on the on the negative side of things
uh kind of the same thing as you like I
feel like a piece of [__] son too hey
what's up but it's in the way that like
you know clock's always ticking yeah and
you would think Common Sense wise as
your parents get older then you're gonna
be there more and I definitely am there
less and my parents live 20 minutes away
from me for some [__] reason I can't
do it there's just so much trauma though
it's hard it's weird it's like you just
and like I was saying like you find like
that's the time that I get responsible
about life if I know I have time to
visit my parents and I go oh but I can't
I have to go do this like I should go be
productive and it's like no you [__]
you could have just went over there and
like given a few hours but but also they
have to set up an environment where they
like you want to [__] see them all
that's very true yeah I think and to be
fair they have like they're so [__]
cool today and they're and they're great
but again it's just the old habits it's
like it takes a lot of [__] time Joe
his dad's like hey we should like be
more open and [__] randomly clown on
his ass yeah
yeah that was that was freaking 30 years
ago that's true yeah people don't forget
I think that's the part that they're
holding on to the Past obviously and
that's informing the now and it's just
not in yeah it's not in the reflex yet
to uh to take on the responsibility and
act on it I think this year's the year
for that of like I mean you may not have
next year to do it you know so it's like
I heard that kids do bring families
together though like because now there's
a reason for the family to me still have
the cabinet yeah have a kid don't do it
already I
mom if she wanted me to have a kid if I
if she felt like it was something that
was taking too long and she was like oh
just get married that's okay
I was like you're sweet not at the
Whitlock I don't think they don't put a
pressure on me to do that but I think it
really is if there's one thing that I
would like to
work on diligently it's just shut the
[__] up and go see them
thank you
yeah I mean they live in freaking Downy
man it's so close yeah I relate to that
heavy because when my dad passed away I
thought I was doing like him Proud by
always working and always focusing on
being productive yeah and when he passed
away I was like damn like
there's no time like the present in fact
that's true yeah even when I am there
I'm like not there you know what I mean
like I'm in the house I'm face to face
with my mom we're just physically there
but you're right and I'm just like we're
both kind of like so what do you want to
talk about
it's like I don't think adult me ever
developed the correct like rapport with
them so but then I think now is the time
to just who gives a [__] like it doesn't
matter what you have with them you have
the time and there's barely any left yes
what do you got
um
I feel like this year has been going
pretty good really really happy with
this year so far last year was pretty
tough because uh I think from a family
standpoint so that's when attacker was
dealing with like all his seizures and
stuff
and uh this year so far he's been 10
months seizure free wow
he's already been weaned off his first
medication and then in two more months
he'll be off his second medication and
then it will just be on his own and see
if everything is cool
so that's really good and then that was
kind of getting in the way of his school
so like he was like uh he got kicked out
of one school and then with my past I'm
like [__] like there's just it you would
think that like I got kicked out a bunch
of schools because my parents were
immigrants and they didn't have all the
tools to give me the healthy upbringing
that I need but I'm like but me and Geo
don't really have that excuse like we're
both Americans we speak the language
like we know how the school system works
so I would feel like a huge failure if
my kid followed in my footsteps you know
but he uh we found another school he is
he did really really good and the one
thing that was really um that I'm really
happy to have been able to pass on to
him is I grew up with um ADHD so I know
the way that I have to learn is is
different and so in the most bro way how
I like to explain it is um I think most
people can learn like in three sets of
ten so if you're like bench right it's
like three sets of ten they can do all
10 reps what I realized is when you're
on when you have 80d on rep three or
somewhere else so you actually have to
do 10 10 sets of three but at the end of
the day both of you guys get your 30
reps in but you have to do it
differently so most people they can go
English time right and for a whole hour
that never worked for me so with Taiko
what we started doing is to help uh
catch him up because he had to be out of
school for like two or three months when
he ended up getting kicked out before
the next semester started we have to
brush them up on on work and it makes
more sense to go like all right Tucker
here's an hour we're going to work on
English here's another Alice work on
math but I'm like but that didn't work
for me so what we did with him is the 10
sets of three so like just every new
hour we're just gonna brush up on
something for five minutes and then go
play go go play I don't want to burn you
out but then by the end of the day he'll
still get his
uh yeah and we started doing that so
much every single day before breakfast
just five minutes here 10 minutes there
this motherfucker's in kindergarten he's
doing second grade math now wow but he
could like he could add like three
digits over three digits you could do a
multiplication you can read and I'm like
oh [__] just by like us giving that five
minutes and kind of like helping him
learn the way that I wish I was taught
because that's when I am able to because
I understand how add Works he needs more
frequency and like less volume yeah than
the regular person it's gonna be so sick
for him when he has a job and he can
only work for five minutes
[Laughter]
a 24 hour shift but I only work five
minutes at a time
he's somehow a really good employee I
don't know
he makes it worse what the [__] do you
mean eight hour shift it just needs to
work at Google and never leave yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm calling my Dad he just
needs like a remote job at Oracle
say how I learned yeah so that's going
really really good
um and then uh
and the other thing that's going good is
like what's pretty funny is um I've
owned bartleberg for like 10 years and
for the majority of it I think I've been
fat and I think I've always been my mind
I've made it a female like oh I also do
have comedy stuff so I don't have to be
like fit or whatever so I feel like I
gave myself a lot of like excuses and
crutches
and so last year was the first year I
was like you know what [__] this [__]
like I always feel like I'm like holding
myself back because I I'm like hiding
behind certain personality traits I'm
like I should just go full in like if I
just go full in Into Fitness so I ended
up doing a marathon like two years ago
and then last year I started losing
weight and then I always told myself I
would never do a bodybuilding show
because
um I just like I don't have a discipline
to stick to diets or whatever and and
all that stuff so yes I was already like
kind of giving myself that like this is
why I'll never do it this is why I'll
fail or whatever you know and I was like
that probably means the thing that I say
I'll never do I don't want to do is
probably the thing I should be doing the
most well to break out the limited
beliefs yeah for real so that's why I
went hardcore uh this year and I've
actually dieted for like a whole year
now and I went from like 20 almost 30
body fat almost down to like 10 now and
I have a show in two weeks money
say your money's a great so yeah I have
a show
in two weeks and I feel really good like
this is the best shape I've ever been in
my life and look phenomenal by the way
thank you yeah yeah I think you're gonna
be less than me and this is the first
time in our friendship where he's gonna
weigh less than me that's a big deal
known Joe for like almost 20 years he
knew me when I was 130 pounds
[__] and it's cool because
um next year I turned 40. so I feel like
I'm alley-ooping myself that's a massive
alley-oop yeah I'm like okay cool I'm
gonna enter my 40s in the best shape of
my life even when I did martial arts
before
um because I've always been heavier set
I was like I can never last more than
like a round or two and then now my
conditioning is actually like really
good I feel super good I feel athletic
and I feel like I'm like
in a really good physical shape to be
good dad good husband and all that stuff
so like I feel like everything is going
super good but like you guys
the part that I feel like that's my
invisible list that I need to work on is
for sure my mom and I think there's a
lot of trauma there so like I don't want
to be a good son by obligation and like
going through the motions I want to feel
it so I'm trying to uh work work on work
on because I'm from the outside it might
look like I'm a good sir oh he talks to
his mom here in a little bit like that's
like a physical shell you know but the
inside it's like I'm [__] resisting
the whole time yeah so I'm trying to get
myself to a point where like we can have
some healing and it feels like
um my mom's really receptive and I think
she wants the same so hopefully she
could be less annoying or we could get
there
that's awesome
even green dude what you got brother
dude look I'll be honest it's I'm gonna
be 38 this month at the end of the month
and uh it's it's one of those things
where you know I think if I told myself
when I was like 15 years old you're
gonna be 38 you're not gonna have kids
you're gonna be you're gonna love your
wife more than anything but she won't
she won't do anal I would say that's
[__]
no but because you're like all women
will give me anal yeah of course they
want to [__] in the butt that's all this
that's what the porn says yeah but no I
think for me design for it for me I
think that you know gosh so many things
have happened I think it all for me it
all comes from my mission statement like
I'm one of those people who's just
driven by by one [__] thing and for
me it's Revenge
so your mission statement is one word
that's it yeah that's it pretty simple
look I turned 28 000 into a million
dollars twice
and then the [__] world came back and
[__] me and you know what this next
run I'm gonna [__] it right back
that's what it's all about all about
police
at least some wood today Nick got
someone today who are you getting
revenge on the [__] world the world
well mostly no Juan the multinational
the multinational the multinational
conglomerates who [__] us yeah like
probably Alameda research FTX these guys
yeah they [__] Luna during the you
know the d-peg incident and you know
he's not even getting in trouble for it
no he's not he's getting a [__]
sweetheart deal from the justice
department pieces of [__] hell yeah I
can't wait to Wave My Flag but you know
yeah but also you know Nikki has been
pivoting from like being being tuber
scum to like
doing more poker stuff and so it's been
honestly so fun like just to just to
like be in those circles it feels like
early YouTube again like in a way that I
haven't experienced in forever yeah um
because we were both there early tuber
stages and like when barely anyone was
even doing tuber and everyone thought
you were [__] dumb and tuber's coming
back then yeah so I'll come full circle
now I call him now I call him yeah but
that's the point right it's like it's
one of those things where
I just think that
you know I got hit hard I got caught one
pants with my pants down if you will
um but it's all about how you react to
it it's all about how you respond and
how you get up from it and that's what
I'm in the middle of doing right now but
it's a process so yeah it is pretty cool
to see that transformation not even
transformation but like that attitude of
like yeah I got [__] over but wait to
see the next one it is pretty [__]
cool to see it's fun dude but it's fun
because especially because if you've
been there before and I have you're like
well I have the tools to do it again so
it'll be fine but it just sucks to have
to wait yeah like that's the patience
game the patience game that's exactly
why I did what I did because I don't
have the patience you do to just wait
for the the seasons to change for sure I
gotta stay active I know I'll go [__]
crazy but for me
it's we're at the stage right now three
months to make it yep and then the
Bitcoin having is going to come and then
shit's gonna get [__] crazy again and
then everyone's gonna be fomoing in but
I'm already in the black because I've
been dcing the whole [__] run and
it's just about discipline not being
stupid knowing why you bought what you
bought and not [__] it up because you
could [__] it all up right here so but
then
God you guys are nailing it today my ma
like I could be a better son for sure
I've been saying that for years I think
but I I always think it's good to want
to be a better son anyway but my mom
just lost her mom and so you know I
think I could be a way better son that
way
um I've been kind of avoiding her on the
phone but I kind of always do that but
like it's just because it's such a
bummer because she just lost her mind
and my mom's a hoarder and she was like
going through all her stuff and she's
like sending us pictures of like random
toys like I give a [__] she's like
here's a Ninja Turtle with his hair
burned off and I'm like I didn't even
know these girls had hair that's like my
mom she always sends me [__] she
sends me pictures of a [__]
vegetarian lunch I'm like I don't give a
[__]
you guys ever tell your mom's like the
reason why I don't talk to you is you're
not that entertaining that's a good ice
cream well I did tell my mom yesterday
or two days ago I was like
our release should be better if we
weren't so annoying
what'd she say she says can you please
teach me to not be annoying
that would crush me to death I'd have to
take a knee and then I had a follow-up
right after I was like the first step is
actually listening because she's the
type of person that's like if I like
this everyone else does so I show you
love by giving you what I like but I'm
like the oatmeal cookies comes in I've
already told you he [__] hates
oatmeal cookies and you give them 12 000
of them he's not feeling any of your
love so she actually went out to buy
chocolate chip wow that sounds like
she's learning you know
also very quickly very thankful for this
place love you guys seriously looking
very nice seriously seriously this place
is a godsend I hope everyone you know
I'm really glad that we hit the two mil
that's awesome but like I hope that like
you know hope we're back into the growth
period and where everyone like I can
tell everyone apart everyone's really
excited to be here but like I'm excited
to just keep on testing new formats with
you guys and [__] around and having
fun and like I don't know you guys are
the best this is still like to be honest
like this is the realest place in my
life
it really is like everybody's actually
saying the thing that they want to say
yeah credit to Joe and Bart for creating
that environment and maintaining that
environment right not easy you guys are
[__] amazing you know it's we can't
make this happen if it's just me and
Bart talking all day yeah we have to
collect down ass people to have an
actual group conversation and be on the
same page yeah and always get each
other's backs yeah yeah and we went
through a lot of people they came and
went but still you know it's like I
think like it's just hard to find that
right yeah it is yeah but it really does
feel like we're all like just it's all
just friends again yeah which is tight
yep
like and I feel and then the audience
feels it too like they love the new era
they that's why they're here you know
yeah
I can't break it up
yeah Nick's gonna destroying why I left
JK dude say your number dude what the
[__] your number say your money is a
great responsible show me your abs then
say your money drama alert does a tweet
Nick Dunn is done at JQ
by the way I really love say your money
as a response to show your dick
save your money save it